In today's video we're going to see what happens when you try to boil superglue and we'll try and answer the question is superglue flammable
Superglue is super interesting stuff also known as cyanoacrylate this glue works form a very quick and strong bond
Most people have only used or bought superglue in some very small quantities it often comes in
Tiny tubes that only have a few drops in them, but we've gotten our hands on an 8 ounce container of superglue
That's a full cup of superglue all in one spot. There are a few different things
I would really like to try using this much superglue. The first thing I want to try is heating it up
I want to see if you can boil superglue and if you can what happens to it, here's the basic idea
We're going to empty 8 ounces of our superglue into a saucepan
That won't be used for anything else then boil it on a hot plate
What do you think is going to happen will the superglue just evaporate?
Will it catch on fire or do you think it's going to explode we're doing this outside today?
Because even if you aren't boiling it super glue puts off some pretty powerful fumes
It can irritate your throat your eyes and your skin and I figure that when we heat it up
Those fumes are gonna be multiplied by quite a bit and I really don't want that in any confined space
So we're in a nice open area
We've even got a fair breeze passing through which should make it easy to avoid breathing in any of these fumes
first a very quick test as
to the stickiness of super glue
My gloves and my gloves and now glue it together
peel apart
It does the exact same thing if you get it on your skin
But it really hurts to try and peel it apart
this much super glue is actually fairly dangerous because if this got on you in any large quantities,
It could require medical intervention to get it off
like if this were to spill all over my clothing
It could stick my clothing onto my skin and I wouldn't be able to pull it off
So I have to be very careful not to get any of this on you
This stuff is amazingly thin and clear. It really just looks like water I
Don't want to waste this super glue
But just because I've never actually seen this much super glue out of a container in one spot
You got to play with it a little bit
I'm gonna feel slightly slightly oily on my fingers right now
Which I'm sure would glue together if I tell them you can see little bits where it's been
Done you could glue as it dries out. It's just it just feels like you know water or thin oil
It's pretty nuts. I'll see if I can glue my glove onto this rock
I am NOT holding on to this rock. It's holding on to me. Really
The glue hasn't completely cured so I can probably pull my fingers apart and make it drop the rock let's try it
Kind of
All right, since I don't want my movement permanently arrested I'm gonna take this glove off and put anyway
We're ready to turn on our stove, but I've got one more thing
I want to do just to protect everything before I do that and that's just to put a sheet of foil
over our hot plate in case the superglue
Boils up and out or something like that. I don't want to spill superglue all over this plate
So just one piece of foil going across the top that's it
All right. Let's turn this on to low the breeze we've got going on might make this take a little bit longer than normal
I'm not sure we'll be able to tell the difference since I've
Never boiled superglue before I don't even know if it will boil. It might just heat up for light on fire
Smoke a lot
We've got fumes I don't think I can call that steam since I don't think cyanoacrylate glue
Contains any water, but it's vapor of some kind
(random grunts)(eww nate!) Oh boy!
That that went from zero to extremely powerful in no time at all. Oh
Good thing we are not doing this indoors or I'm pretty sure the whole indoors would be like that Oh,
still in my eyes
Got me again I was upwind. (JUST USE A FRIGGIN MASK OR SOMETHING NATE!)
We've got some good white vapor coming off of the saucepan with the superglue in it
But I want to try turning the heat up. It's not really changing much
It's been doing the same little bit of vapor thing for like five minutes now. I think it needs more heat
Let's take it up to medium
Fun fact superglue was developed while trying to find a way to make custom lenses
Very breezy
Oh
We are starting to get some bubbles at the bottom of the pan and it looks a lot like when you're heating up water
So maybe this is gonna boil. I want to help it along. So it's been on medium for almost 10 minutes now
I think it's time that we turn it up to high
All right a lot of white vapor and as my cameraman and I can both attest it sucks if you get too near it
So glad it's breezy since we've got a nice steady stream of air going that way I can get a nice up close to it
Put it stick in it. Ooh, I hear bubbly noises see bubbly things a
Little bit there's so much of this vapor now hard to get close to it and really look at what's going on in there. ( Use a mask man! Not that hard!)
Even though the vapor is being taken away this fast. I
Can't really see much down into the bottom. Oh
It's so fast in its pane
Just a tiny bit of it goes toward your face and all the sudden it stings kids do not try this at home
Or at a friend's house or in some random yard. Just don't try this. You'll get that vapor all over you and it will suck
That's some good boiling action going on in there. Now. That's that we can see it through the vapor. Oh
Man, it's almost gone. Like most of this is burning away and it's kind of a yellowish green color in there now
Had no color when we started very clear looked just like water. Oh wow
It's evenly this and goopy stuff. I can got strings of it coming off on the stick. Oh, I think we are just about out
Superglue is all boiled and burned away
The fumes certainly seem to be gone
All that's left is a very sticky
Not glue sticky, but like gooey residue at the bottom of this pan
when heck of a nonstick coating
You can superglue isn't sticking to it
This is the result of boiling away one entire cup of cyanoacrylate glue
there's this residue stuff which
Has really lost most of that power that super glue has like putting it near my nose
Breathing in I can smell the superglue smell, but it's not burning. It's not making my eyes water
Pretty mild
Compared to even just a normal little bottle of superglue if you just smell that
Usually it'll make you flinch. It's kind of acrid burns the inside of your nose a little bit. This is just
Yeah, it smells kind of like superglue. I'm not gonna taste it
I taste a lot of things not gonna taste this that's amazing. How much of it is gone
So that means most of what's in superglue
Can be boiled away
some white powdery residue
Up on the sides
That looks like it might have built up just from the vapor
Rather than the liquid disappearing. We do have some more superglue and there's one more test
I want to try with it right now and that's just to see what happens if we apply a more direct heat is
Superglue flammable, we're gonna pour some superglue down into the saucepan then take a blowtorch and see if we can light it on fire
You have season flames
Oh
I think I did it
That's that's it. Superglue is flammable. It doesn't light quite like gasoline or even alcohol
It took a little bit of time to really catch but once it caught it seems to be burning quite nicely
whoo now
All of the superglue is hot enough that it's boiling in the saucepan when we heated the saucepan up on the stove
We had a lot of very thick white smoke that burned
my nose and my eyes and my lungs if I even got a little whiff of it and this is burning and it's boiling I
Don't see any white smoke. So I think the vapors themselves coming off of the superglue
Or getting burned up and are therefore not able to react the same way if it gets in my face a little bit it kind
Of smells like I don't know it kind of smells a little bit like some fireworks. Oh
And there's the white stuff and we don't want any of that that is the result of lighting superglue on fire
Yeah, it really does have a skunk smell to it
Heating superglue on a stove until it boils and lighting it on fire
interesting results from both of them
Here's a challenge
What are some things we could do with large quantities of superglue that we haven't already thought of liquid nitrogen?
I already thought about it vacuum chamber. I already thought about it dry-ice already thought about it furnace. I already thought about it
Give us something new we want you to get creative with this one
Tell us your thoughts and if we use an idea of yours that we haven't already come up with will send you 25 bucks
guys, we still have more for you to see that little box up at the top will transport you directly to our last video if
You haven't seen it. You should go watch it
If you have seen it
Maybe watch it again
The box at the bottom will show you what YouTube thinks you should be watching next and this bomb here in the center will subscribe
You to our channel, so you never miss a video
Don't forget to ring that Bell and we will see you in the next one. Talk to you then